un análisis y un repaso breve De qué
está ocurriendo en Ucrania Allí está
nuestras enviadas especiales Catalina
Gómez Ángel quien está en kiev la
capital también nos acompaña Irene sabio
desde harquif y Emmanuel jazz desde
boucha comenzamos entonces Santiago con
Catalina y bienvenidas a nuestras tres
enviadas especiales a
ucraniadas especiales que a lo largo de
todos estos meses han estado trabajando
en terreno Por supuesto enviándonos en
material de absoluta calidad para toda
nuestra audiencia Catalina estás en la
capital ucraniana Cómo amanece quieven
este aniversario tras las palabras del
presidente bolodimirse háblenos un poco
de la situación de los combates en el
país hoy por hoy
Santiago y María clara muy buenos días
amaneció siendo un frío más común de lo
normal o por lo menos de esta semana
pero también con la noticia de que hasta
ahora no han sonado las alarmas en la
capital kiev había muchísima expectativa
había nerviosismo en la ciudad hasta el
momento transcurre Un día normal lleno
de homenajes y recuerdo de lo que ha
sido este último año aquí estuvo muy
cerca donde nos encontrábamos al frente
en la Plaza de Santa Sofía el presidente
selensky o manejando muchos de los
soldados que han defendido el país
durante este año y dando y declarando
Héroes de la patria Aquí también donde
nos encontramos estuvo el Primer
Ministro de Polonia haciendo un homenaje
a quienes han caído en combate y quienes
han fallecido Durante este año pero
también médicos también gente que ha
ayudado los rescates bomberos y todos
los que han ayudado a defender a Ucrania
desde el 24 de febrero en un momento en
que si bien la situación en la capital
está tranquila en el don báez donde se
centra la mayoría de las batallas sigue
siendo una situación bastante complicada
los ataques son cada vez mayores en Back
mood una ciudad que viene siendo
asediada por las tropas rusas recordemos
desde el pasado verano y pero cada vez
están más cerca de la ciudad incluso la
vía que va camino ha sido bombardeada en
las últimas horas Así que esa es la
situación ha dicho el presidente selenzi
que ellos van a soportar y van a estar
en vacuna hasta cuando consideren
necesario pero también no dudarían en
retirarse Y eso significa también
presión de las tropas rusas en muchos
otros frentes de este este del país
donde tratan de buscar los puntos
débiles del ejército ucraniano que sigue
resistiendo Y hoy ha recibido la noticia
ya de que los primeros tanques leopardos
se encuentran en el país lo que ayudará
más a esa batalla especialmente en ese
lugar tan difícil
catalino y como ustedes bien lo decía en
este momento los combates se concentran
en el este de Ucrania sin embargo
recordemos que a principios de la
invasión esta embestida tenía un punto
específico jarkid que es donde está
nuestra corresponsal Irene sabio Irene
usted está en la que es la segunda
ciudad más importante del país y como ya
lo mencionaba uno de los intentos
iniciales de Rusia fue tomarse todo el
oblast de harkid Sin embargo los
ucranianos lograron resistir cuéntenos
Cuál es la importancia de esta ciudad y
si hay temores de un segundo intento de
invadir a
sí efectivamente existe este tumor
estamos en una zona rusofana aquí la
cantidad de ciudadanos que hablan rusos
Es mayor que en otras zonas del país
además también estamos a menos de 50
kilómetros de la frontera con Rusia
donde según algunas informaciones hay
una importante concentración de unidades
militares el es la segunda ciudad más
importante de Ucrania es un importante
centro Industrial también ha sido antes
de la guerra lo importante motor
económico para este país y como ustedes
decían ha estado bajo asedio pero
también después de que la ofensiva
ucraniana lograse alejar a las atrapas
rusas esta ciudad ha continuado a ser
sometida a numerosos ataques que se
pueden se pueden ver en la ciudad
caminando por las calles las
instrucciones evidentemente hay
edificios parcialmente o completamente
destrozados que recuerdan esta situación
una parte de los 18 millones de personas
que necesitan asistencia humanitaria
según Naciones Unidas que se encuentran
aquí así como en las regiones adyacentes
Y nosotros también en estas horas que
hemos pasado en la ciudad hemos oído en
varias ocasiones las sirenas sonar en
esta ciudad a estas mismas semana ha
habido un ataque contra un edificio no
muy lejos de aquí de donde nos
encontramos en este momento en un barrio
de la norte de la ciudad de según
algunas Fuentes era un edificio que
albergaba drones ucranianos Y por
supuesto la situación también es
complicada en esas zonas recientemente
retomadas por el ejército ucraniano en
otras partes de esta provincia o también
en esas zonas que aún están bajo
ocupación rusa esta mañana hablamos con
las autoridades locales que nos
comentaron que hay todavía 29 aldeas y
ciudades de esta región que están bajo
la ocupación de las tropas rusas por
tanto si la situación aquí todavía es
muy delicada muy tensa
Muchísimas gracias por este reporte
bueno dejar que vamos ahora a bucha que
recordemos ha sido uno de los
principales escenarios de los presuntos
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
así María Clara tuvo lugar uno de los
episodios más polémicos y cruentos de
esta guerra cuando recordemos que fueron
encontradas fosas comunes con cadáveres
con signos de haber sido torturados así
se encuentra Emanuel yacemanuel Bueno
cuéntenos qué ha ocurrido en bucha no un
poco lo estaba adelantando recién ha
sido escenario de lo que decíamos se
denuncian como crímenes de guerra por
parte de Moscú
exactamente hablamos en este caso de un
mes de ocupación rusa aquí en bucha un
mes de oro de escenas de olor Y aquí
mismo en esta calle
diablozca con una población
víctima de parte del ejército ruso
hablamos al menos de 400 y 19
civiles asesinados y más torturados
También hablé con el alcalde de la
ciudad que también habla de la gente que
desapareció
desaparecí el año pasado
que también aquí hablamos de torturas
muchas torturas y faltaban más personas
desaparecidas esto constituye
naturalmente crímenes de guerra como
como más de
65.000 otros en todo el país y por eso
cada uno de estos crímenes está siendo
investigando por por Ucrania también la
Corte Penal Internacional los estados
aliados de Ucrania y también los
están investigando cada casos aquí